turning now to one of the hardest
working filmmakers in the movie industry
we're talking about the great ava
duvernay
who is expressing her commitment to a
more inclusive hollywood with a brand
new initiative
it's a database called array crew and it
connects hiring managers and talented
crew members in film and tv
who are women and people of color here's
an example of why this is needed look at
the numbers an analysis
of 300 top grossing films found less
than one percent of camera operators
were female
and only six percent of editors were
people of color
their database is a partnership between
ava duvernay and former
warner brothers tv exec that's peter
roth duvernay
is also committed to inclusion in her
own projects
every single episode of her
groundbreaking series clean sugar
on own as a woman in the director's
chair go eva
here's one of the show stars bianca
lawson on why that's so important
queen sugar is really a trailblazer the
innovator of
having all female directors having a
totally
inclusive crew and cast and
such diversity that we rarely ever see
in other shows and
sets so i really feel like clean sugar
has really been at the forefront
of a shift that's happening right now
within the business
a beautiful shift i'll say ava ava
duvernay joins us now there she is the
brains and the beauty behind what bianca
calls this
beautiful shift so ava good morning to
you we're all here at the table so good
morning
friends good morning i know that you've
been working on this thinking about this
for at least the past two years
what is it that you saw that you said we
need to do something and by we you said
i'm gonna do something
well i would just walk on sets and not
see enough people who look not
like me not enough women not enough
people of color not enough people who
are
older even you know um um over 60
being older in our in our industry not
enough people with disabilities i mean
it's really the
idea that our our crews should reflect
the real world and they can
so often though when you talk to people
about why why don't we have more
inclusion on our sets they just say well
we don't know where to find people
so i thought well maybe we can help with
that so what was your pitch to the
studios number one how many people have
signed on
and what was your pitch you i cannot
even believe i'm saying this
every single major studio is signed on
wow
and streamer over the last two years
very detailed conversations
um have signed on and the pitch was
really
um you are making so much so many
shows and films right now why not get a
little help with crewing up
hey ava it's a big deal and a big
accomplishment just to have built the
database but i'm curious going forward
how will you monitor if at all whether
it's being implemented and used
as it should be well we have a whole
system of
checks and balances for people to really
report into us the hiring side producers
are you finding people on crew and then
crew members to have this kind of badge
of honor when they get
hired off of crew we have 70 productions
currently using it
across all of the studios there are 3
000 crew members in the database now
and it's growing every day yeah it
sounds like an industry story ava but do
you see it bigger than the industry
i do it might sound like it's just about
hollywood but really
we all consume we all watch and enjoy
what comes out of hollywood and so
it matters the way that it's made it
matters the intention behind these
things that there is
inclusion that there is belonging
because i believe that the way that the
set feels and looks
embeds itself in the image you end up
watching the way it was made so why
don't we
create a more balanced way of making the
work so that we can enjoy it even more
ava when you look on imdb and you look
up your name
it says you have 14 upcoming projects
how do you keep track of 14 upcoming
projects how do the pots on the stove
not all boil over
and anthony she doesn't look tired no
you know i i you know i i there there
are women before me who have juggled
oprah shonda uh men before me jj
spielberg these are the people i aspire
to and so i follow in their footsteps
let's talk about one of those projects
if you can just pick one out for now to
talk about let's talk about queen
sugar which uh shut down production
because of the pandemic then reopen and
as i understand it
you've reworked the storyline to bring
covet and black
black lives matter into the script what
was that process like
well we had written all of the episodes
and uh and then and then the pandemic
hit and so we went down like the rest of
hollywood when we came back we thought
well we can't use those old episodes
that don't address everything that
happened in 2020 so we decided to
rewrite it very quickly
and it is a show that really uh the
season is a time capsule of 2020
all the things that everyone went
through you know the fear about you know
covet and the election and and black
lives matter and
you know at food scarcity i think it's a
tribute to the survival
that we all have gone through and making
it through 2020. i thought this was cool
ava for the first time a poster of queen
sugar
was on the warner brothers lot listen i
was with queen sugar from the very
beginning i remember when you were
writing it
what was it like for you to see a poster
and warner brothers
it started as a small show and it really
does have a fervent cult following
yeah but the audience grows each season
and so for us to be
uh you know on the big the billboard on
the side of the studio was a real real
honor real pleasure a thrill
we've been talking a lot uh about cicely
tyson
uh and gail's last interview with her
and some of the words of wisdom that she
left all of us with
that continue to echo uh you you're
familiar with the work you knew her over
the years are there particular things
that she said or that you heard
her say uh that stick with you oh gosh
i'll get emotional and gail's last
interview with her was
extraordinary and she said everything
that she wanted to say
uh the last uh acting um that she did
was on
our show uh cherish today she was one of
the stars of our show
and so i got to know her really well she
was supportive of me since my very first
film
12 years ago the main thing she said to
me is don't worry
just keep working hard don't worry keep
your eye on the ball and just keep going
we get so bogged down and
in in the little pieces and the worry
and she said make sure you take keeping
your eye on the bigger picture
don't worry keep going and uh i hear you
say that to me and i intend to
she actually went to your first film at
the only
theater it was playing in on the east
coast when it came out
you went to the oh it was the only
theater in washington dc i get a call
out of the blue
i'm able to book this one small theater
somehow her friend mignon
took her to see this independent film by
someone that she didn't know
she called me after she said my dear
this is cecily tyson i just want to tell
you
your film is lovely and i want you to
keep going and we had a lovely
conversation
and we stayed in touch ever since what a
thrill for my path my little path to
cross with her
magnificent life so i miss her um but
well done right 96 years of beauty
ava thank you so much congratulations
congratulations
bravo the new season of queen sugar airs
on tuesdays on
own